bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur tv fil
78 si vous nous rejoignez pour ce
nouveau numéro du 7 8 sociétés
le thème de ce soir porte sur
l'épuisement au travail communément
appelé le burn out
plus de trois millions d'actifs français
seraient concernés
pourtant le burn out ne sera pas
reconnue comme une maladie
professionnelle
l'amendement à la loi sur le dialogue
social déposé par benoît hamon député de
la 11e circonscription des yvelines a
été jugée irrecevable
alors faut-il ou pas reconnaître le burn
out comme une maladie professionnelle
n'hésitez pas à réagir sur le twitter de
l'émission hashtag 7,8 société qu'est ce
que le burn-out quels en sont les
symptômes comment le prévenir pourquoi
le medef et ils opposés à une critique
une classification pardon du burn out
dans la catégorie maladies
professionnelles on en parle avec nos
invités ils sont quatre autour de la
table
françoise françois d'abord qui est
psychologue du travail et spécialisés et
fondatrice de l'association maison et
souffrances mais on souffrance et
travail 78 donc une maison qui existe
depuis mars 2013 bonsoir daniel lemay
nier vous êtes avec nous pour témoigner
vous êtes vous avez été victime d'un
burn out et puis vous vous expliquerez
un petit peu comment tout ça s'est passé
bertand de près président du medef se
sont dits vide dont soir merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation et enfin martin
et guerrier secrétaire national si fo
cgc en charge de la santé au travail des
conditions de travail et du handicap
bonsoir alors pour débuter cette
émission nous recevons par téléphone
benoît hamon donc député de la 11e
circonscription des yvelines bonsoir
alors vous avez déposé un amendement à
la loi sur le dialogue social pour que
le burn out soit considérée comme une
maladie professionnelle
votre amendement a été retoqué c'est un
échec pour vous il était jugé recevable
un cahier qui était vincent le rappelle
l'article 40
ils sont entraînés au soucieux de les
administrateurs de commissions des
finances des possibles
mon père et les parlementaires n'ont pas
le droit de déposer des amendements qui
entraîne des dépenses supplémentaires
pour l'état il ya deux amendements
turcot même été adopté notre lien avec
le gouvernement il m'en réjouis dès
qu'ils captent progresse vers ce qui
pourrait être demain une reconnaissance
du syndrome d'épuisement professionnel
comme dans la vie professionnelle
alors il faut être un peu précis le
dornan c'est pas une maladie en soi est
un tableau clinique de différents
différents symptômes qui annonce sont
annonciateurs de ce qui précède souvent
un effondrement ou un épuisement
professionnel
ces soins liés à beaucoup surcharge de
travail un trop plein de pression un
trop plein de travail qui amènent des
hommes des femmes quel que soit leur
niveau de responsabilité et ça concerne
les simples employés comme les cadres de
très haut niveau dans le public comme le
privé on dit beaucoup de nos
compatriotes parfois s'effondrer et le
notre objectif c'est contre une
dépression ou une affection psychique
directement liée à l'organisation du
travail est bien fait qu'elle soit
reconnue comme une maladie
professionnelle ne poursuivant pas
d'autre objectif que celui là il avait
reçu beaucoup de témoignages depuis que
vous avez un
allez on va dire mener ce combat est
lancé ce combat contre les ravages
considérables doit même vous dire que je
crois fort jamais été autant sollicité
sur ce sujet alors parce qu'il renvoie
beaucoup de situations vécues le cabinet
technologia que trois bulles de vian
français exposés à un risque de burn out
on sait aujourd'hui que les nouvelles
formes d'organisation du travail le
management par le stress conduit parfois
des salariés donc à s'effondrer
non c'est surtout que ça peut concerner
des grandes entreprises de services
comme des hôpitaux comme sont de grands
noms comme d'administration sans l'objet
de deux grandes transformations ça n'est
ni le monopole du privé ni monopole du
public et je le redis denis le monopole
des employés discuter car cela concerne
tout le monde
le meilleur exemple puisque le bds
s'opposent à la reconnaissance d'une
autre maladie professionnelle c'est que
pas plus tard qu'il ya quelques mois
c'est le président de bnp paribas tient
dorna ou plus ne doute pas que ça existe
la question aujourd'hui c'est de savoir
si on le reconnaît comme maladie
professionnelle commencée des pressions
de ces affections psychiques
directement liée à ce tremplin de
travail et quelle suite allez-vous
donner alors à ceux reçus d'une partie
en tout cas de l'amendement que vous
avez déposé
écoutez on va continuer je vais déposer
une proposition de loi
l'objectif c'est de poursuivre à la
rentrée le débat en clair il ya deux
options soit on inscrit on reconnaît le
syndrome d'épuisement professionnel
comme une maladie professionnelle et il
est officiellement inscrit au tableau
des maladies professionnelles mais comme
vous avez des représentants de 3,7 à
ségécé du medef ils ont diront que c'est
compliqué mais qu'en tout cas les
partenaires sociaux ne sont pas parvenus
à se mettre d'accord jusqu'ici c'est la
première option
ça ne me semble être la meilleure mais
si jamais vous n'avez pas aboutir sur ce
terrain là il existe aujourd'hui une
autre voie pour voir sa dépression son
affection psychique reconnue comme une
maladie professionnelle donc du lié à
son environnement de travail
on appelle la voix complémentaires sauf
qu'aujourd'hui elle et c'est très
difficile pour un salarié de d'obtenir
la reconnaissance des pressions ou d'un
burn out comme une maladie
professionnelle parce qu'il faut
atteindre un seuil d'incapacité de 25%
c'est à celui ci tellement élevés qu'en
france
l'année dernière on était reconnu que
200 et quelques quintaux plus le burn
out comme maladie professionnelle canton
belgique où les vols des chiffres de
19000 walek
il ya un vrai problème de non
reconnaissance de maladie
professionnelle
alors elle bertrand baston devons rester
avec nous venons vraiment encore une
petite minute bertrand de créer
présidente du medef 60 dit qu'il voulait
réagir à vos propos le prix de nos
amants bonjour je regarde vous ne soyez
pas barbie nous j'aurai le plaisir de
vous voir dire que le medef s'oppose au
burn-out prénationale c'est un peu court
le meeddat la position du medef
aujourd'hui dehors c'est de se dire que
toute affection qui touche les personnes
doit être prise au sérieux et on doit
ensemble trouver des solutions pour
résoudre
notre position est plutôt justement de
dire aujourd'hui maj même quand j'ai
préparé cette émission pour venir il a
fallu que renseigne un petit peu
aujourd'hui et ça vous nous répondre et
peut-être madame puisque vous êtes non
psychologue psychologue psychologue burn
out j'ai cherché une main une dépression
est ce que c'est pareil d'abord
qu'est-ce que c'est ce que la différence
aujourd'hui je n'ai vu aucun avantage
j'avais une question de faire l'impasse
et paris tout de suite de but en blanc
le mettre en
parce que mona moi je me dirai si vous
confirmez ce que vous avez dit mais j'ai
entendu dans vos propos pas aujourd'hui
mais dans d'autres choses que j'ai pu
lire que vous mettiez à la charge de
l'entreprise à la charge directement
l'entreprise et qu'elle devrait comme
une réparation salon rien des malades
ils savent peut-être le cas voilà
justement c'est toute l'ambiguïté c'est
pour ajouter une pathologie
multifactorielle
quels sont les vrais facteurs
déclenchants si d'aventuré on arrive
elle est déterminée alors il ya un
travail à faire
les de but en blanc comme sylvain savait
par apco
benoît hamon vous écoute bond en avant
mais il est cuit jamais et ans je suis
dans sa tournée nationale je suis sorti
donc pour pouvoir répondre à vos
questions via sûr évidemment préféré par
milou de visu bon effectivement tendue
que j'ai entendu qui dit écoute une
dépression est ce qu'elle y lit alors
l'exclu travail mais ce qu'elle est lié
par un logo fait que vous aviez connu
une situation privée à peu compliqué et
il y à partir du moment où ce serait
multi factorielle on ne pourrait pas le
reconnaître comme une maladie
professionnelle
bon d'abord je voudrais juste rappeler
quand on a reconnu les cancers du poumon
liés à l'amiante comme des maladies
professionnelles qu'on n'a pas été
ensuite faire l'inventaire de ce qui
était reconnu comme victime de l'amiante
comme son regard dans ceux qui avaient
eu qui fumaient un paquet meeting et
ceux qui n'assumait pas et on savait
qu'ils avaient fourni des causes aussi
multifactorielle à des cancers du poumon
donc on peut avoir des causes
multifactorielles et
man à 10 des cancers du poumon en
l'occurrence reconnu comme maladie
professionnelle
cet argument des plusieurs facteurs je
le reçois mais en tout cas il n'a pas
empêché la reconnaissance d'un certain
nombre de maladies comme maladie
professionnelle
ensuite la réparation ça c'est à dire
quand ici on démontre qu'à sa tombe
fonctions psychiques sont directement
liés à l'organisation du travail
yves est logique en ce cas le patronat
c'est toujours dans cette tradition
l'alc les bains ce soit à la charge de
l'entreprise de réparer le vco mondial
de cette affection
ce n'est pas l'assurance maladie parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est nous tous qui
paient je me relance bis a un coût pour
l'assurance maladie sont les retraités
qui paye les salariés qui paient du tout
mon équipe et celle à nos entreprises
devraient faire tout un bon donc tout
seul benoît maire est d'abord il faut
être sérieux intérêt pas on n'est pas
sur des sommes non plus a
vraisemblablement élevé et j'ajoute
c'est là que je crois que il faut
rappeler que la totalité des
organisations syndicales salariées sont
favorables à la reconnaissance des
affections psychiques liés au travail
comme maladie professionnelle fait qu'à
partir du moment où des entreprises de
tourets être un pur effet traîné à payer
pour la réparation de ces maladies
professionnelles qu'elle serait
évidemment très excitée parce qu'il y en
a un caractère dissuasif
à noter aussi fun que ça s'est déjà vu
dans d'autres domaines se fait ailleurs
par ailleurs benoît hamon on les traîne
la révolution quand même oui très
rapidement pour terminer à les personnes
patron pme et en tant que président de
metz face 118 je dis bien sonner dans
mes adhérents que des tpe et des pme
je vous rappelle benoît hamon 87% driss
française au moins de 50 salariés et
dans des entreprises de 30 10 5 20
salariés le patron il est souvent au
milieu de ses salariés il les connaît
tous il traite des êtres humains pas
avec des matricules il en contact avec
eux assez régulièrement et ne craignez
vous pas en est il n'y a pas de négation
de cette manie postale de maps afin de
n'être pas de cette affection
bailly mais par contre gagné vous pas de
deux justement de faire peser une charge
injuste sur les entrants sur ses
entreprises et ses milliers
d'entreprises qui ont un comportement
vertueux par nature une réponse rapide
s'il vous plaît une réponse la réalité
aujourd'hui c'est que quand vous êtes
dans une entreprise du bâtiment
vous avez vous êtes vous cotisez à la
transaction du travail et maladies
professionnelles en fonction des risques
auxquels sont exposés les salariés donc
on a déjà ce système qui existe que l'on
soit en tpe pme aux grandes entreprises
dont il existe pour d'autres potentiels
accidents du travail ou maladie
professionnelle
donc ce qui me gêne c'est qu'il ya
aujourd'hui incontestablement parce que
le monde de l'entreprise à est votre but
l'organisation du travail et que la
mondialisation est passée par là que les
entreprises de services sont développées
et yale de nouvelles formes
d'organisation du travail qui conduisent
à ce qu'il y ait de nouvelles formes de
souffrance au travail et ils foutent y
répondre moi j'aime dire et tant pis si
elles ne répondent pas luca effet de
voir de quelle manière là où le dialogue
social est bloqué et là où manifestement
n'avance pas c'est la reconnaissance des
maladies professionnelles
de quelle manière on peut relancer la
discussion puisque monsieur évoqué le
fait que les femmes ne sont pas des
matricules craint effectivement
aujourd'hui il faut des réponses à des
hommes et des femmes qui souffrent à la
mairie travaille chez tous voila merci
merci merci monsieur avant de nous avoir
rappelé merci beaucoup aidé alors on va
peut-être continuer sur cet échange
entre entre bertrand de créer et benoît
hamon sur la définition du burn out
il ya une question intéressante comment
on peut faire la différence les
distinguo entre le burn out
la dépression quelle est la part de la
vie privée dans le burn out pour peut
être avoir une connaissance un peu plus
détaillée de skate board a par
définition c'est un d'épuisement à la
fois physique et psychique c'est les
deux en même temps c'est quelqu'un qui
un matin va pas pouvoir aller au travail
alors pas parce qu'il n'a pas envie d'y
aller mais parce que ça ne sera pas
possible
ça se révèle aussi par le biais d'une
dépression c'est des gens qui va falloir
mettre sous antidépresseurs sous
anxiolytiques sous somnifère le
traitement le plus efficace en tous les
cas moi c'est ce que lui je préconise
voilà c'est c'est d'être vraiment
extrait du monde du travail de mettre un
rideau de fer entre le travail et le
salarié pas de téléphone plus de mails
plus de plus rien faire vraiment un vide
autour pour que pour que le salarié
puisse se retrouver sa santé mentale
ces quelques qui va quand il s'effondre
c'est quelqu'un qui est dans la
culpabilité
on a souvent le patient se dit mais
pourquoi moi qu'est ce qui m'arrive je
ne comprends pas ce sont des gens qui en
consultation c'est très difficile de les
convaincre qu'ils sont d'abord en
épuisement professionnel
c'est des gens qu'il faut arrêter donc
il faut négocier l'arrêt de travail
c'est pas il vient pour savoir si
l'arrêt de travail s'est il faut les
convaincre
parce que c'est un argument qu'a été
sortir oui on me demande de
tire-au-flanc où il vend vide
oui non mais j'ai eu un chef
d'entreprise ya pas très longtemps au
téléphone parce que j'ai une de ses
salariés qui est très mal moi j'ai
l'habitude d'envoyer des courriers d'
alerte aux employeurs pour leur dire
attention vous avez un salarié qui est
en difficulté
cette alerte c'est parce que il ya aussi
l'article 41 21 1 du code du travail qui
oblige les employeurs à maintenir en
santé physique et mentale leurs salariés
et que donc du coup si l'employeur ne
sait pas que son salarié est en
difficulté c'est difficile aussi pour
l'employeur de mettre tout en oeuvre
pour pouvoir aider son salarié si
toutefois l'employeur est effectivement
de bonnes volontés a demandé à justin
c'est pas vrai pour trouver son
employeur on va demander justement à
daniel le meunier
vous vous êtes encore en arrêt maladie
donc est ce que vous pourriez mots
nous raconter un petit peu comment es tu
arrivé ce burn out au parcours un petit
peu dans votre entreprise rapidement
et puis comment vous êtes arrivé à se
dorlote bien sûr j'ai en fait j'ai passé
mon baccalauréat je suis venu sur paris
et puis j'ai postulé sur pour une
entreprise qui avait du sens pour moi
dans des valeurs etc
et je pense il restait un an parce que
je souhaitais continuer mes études et
cette entreprise vraiment ma m'a plu
elle m'a convaincue je suis resté parce
qu'on sait très bien ça se passait
vraiment très très bien j'ai grandi
m'ont fait grandir aussi que ce soit au
national à l'international
je peux dire que
ouais j'étais fier d'appartenir à cette
entreprise parce que c'était plein de
valeurs que je respecte et je suis
partagé et puis en 2009 2010
un changement un changement ou une
nouvelle restructuration j'en avais vécu
précédemment et sans aucun problème
parce que effectivement une entreprise
qui grandit bien il faut s'adapter il
faut il faut aller vers le changement
aussi et puis là 2009-2010 et ben on me
demande de changer complètement de
métier c'est un choc pour moi ça m'a
bouleversé je travaille à un univers
complètement différent en fait et je
devais apprendre vraiment un nouveau
métier et je me suis dit bon ben
pourquoi pas après tout donc on m'a dit
on va on va t'accompagner mais ma
compagne est plus ou moins parce que
l'équipe que j'ai intégré étaient déjà
submergées par un travail phénoménal je
devais apprendre un nouvel univers de
travail que ce soit des contacts un
réseau l'informatique c'est vraiment
compliqué au début ça se passe quand
même bien c'est c'est difficile parce
qu'on m'a on ma on m'a intégré dans une
nouvelle équipe on a peut-être que
j'étais pas forcément la bienvenue dans
cette équipe parce que c'était une
équipe qui était là depuis pas mal de
temps et une équipe qui était également
en souffrance et devoir me former en
plus c'était compliqué quand même une
surcharge de travail alimentaire vers le
bord d'un petit pont et j'ai tenu j'ai
voulu tenir parce que c'est pas une
question de fierté parce que cette
entreprise je n'avais pas envie de dire
du mal en fait et en fait on n'a pas
daigné dans ma dans ma réalité et j'ai
dit je peux pas je peux pas je n'ai pas
parlé à ma famille ma famille va aller
très bien et j'avais
hiérarchie oui vous êtes allé voir vos
responsables hiérarchiques peut leur
dire que ça allait pas j'ai voulu passer
un peu sous silence en me disant ça va
se passer ça va se passer c'est pas
évident de faire face à des changements
et cetera il faut que tout le monde
puisse adapter et tout dieu merci ma
famille me portais et m'accompagner
m'ont privé allait très bien très très
bien il va toujours très bien dans cette
question donc effectivement je me suis
dit à un moment parce que je ça n'allait
plus du jeu je me disais blanc je voyais
et noir et tout ce qui était très
basique en fait devenait extrêmement
complexe pour moi et j'ai dit tout ce qu
on vous écoutait pas que vos
responsables de l'ass et autres il fait
les poissons et autres parce qu' il
fallait que ça continue il fallait que
le service soit rendu en temps en heure
on était moindre - de moins de personnes
dans l'entreprise dans le service pardo
et c'était compliqué mois qui débute est
dense dans ce métier je ne demande qu'à
apprendre et je ne pouvais pas à prendre
je ne pouvais pas prendre ce n'était pas
normal pour moi et et je me suis enfermé
en fait dans une bulle et tout ce qui
est tout ce qu'on pouvait me dire je
je l'entendais pas du coup de jour au
lendemain ce fameux bar lounge arrive
alors je concrétise je ne connaissais
pas le terme de burn out j'ai appris je
parle un peu anglais damon et burn out
j'ai entendu c'était on ma on va perdre
on construit on m'a consumer en fait et
je ne comprenais pas ce que ça voulait
dire parce que pour moi cette entreprise
était vraiment quelque chose que du
positif et pilager tout d'un coup je
dégringolait et un soir en rentrant du
travail parce que dans la journée je
faisais face je faisais je gardais le
sourire et en rentrant le soir j'ai j'ai
pu mettre le frein enfin freiner à temps
avant de basculer dans un fossé
gt gt je me suis arrêté un peu plus loin
j'ai et puis voilà j'ai pleuré et puis
je suis rentré chez moi quoi et puis
j'en ai parlé bien sûr à ma famille et
puis j'ai dit je peux pas je peux pas je
ne peux pas il faut que je fasse quelque
chose il faut que je me protège
voilà et c'est important pour moi de
témoigner aujourd'hui
alors martine carrière c'est un dea
certainement des exemples que vous avez
beaucoup vu également
alors qu'est ce qui bloque justement
dans cette reconnaissance peut-être de
ce que vient de nous dire daniel le
meunier sur des symptômes qui semble
être assez clair alors déjà pour nous à
la cfe cgc c'est une grande satisfaction
de voir cette pathologie ce syndrome
d'épuisement professionnel qui rentre
enfin dans la société à l'assemblée
nationale c'est évident c'était évident
qu'on n'allait pas tout de suite arriver
à la créer un tableau de maladies
professionnelles
parce que il faut quelque part quand il
ya un tableau de maladies
professionnelles il faut être sûr d
origine professionnelle et de la
pathologie donc ce sont des termes qui
sont très difficiles mais je pense que
le fait que ça soit maintenant rentrer
dans la société va permettre aux
partenaires sociaux de parler ensemble
de progresser sur le sujet puisque c'est
une demande de la société société
il ya un point qui est très positif le
burn out c'est quelque chose qui est
établie je pense qu'on doit tous
travailler en prévention en amont
c'est important de d'éviter qu'ils aient
d épuisement professionnel dans nos
entreprises que ce soit des tpe ou des
grandes entreprises que les managers et
les cadres soient à l'abri de cette
pathologie est pour ca l'ensemble des
participants du monde de l'entreprise
doit s'en emparer et la direction
générale du travail à a émis un guide
qui est téléchargeable et où le terme de
burn out et bien expliqué et où la
prévention est expliquée pour tous les
professionnels
je pense qu'à la date d'aujourd'hui en
premier lieu c'est nous devons faire de
la prévention dans nos entreprises
les chsct doivent s'emparer du sujet et
doit voir avec les présidents des chsct
et les responsables entreprises ce
qu'est vraiment le grenoble puisque
maintenant il ya une définition qui est
légitime avant on nous disait dans les
entreprises mais le burn out de quoi
vous me parlez maintenant avec cette
définition de la direction générale du
travail nous permet en plus clair c'est
très clair par contre c'est clair pour
faire de la prévention
mais pour la réparation sans trois alors
que les partenaires sociaux
effectivement arrivent à se mettre
d'accord vous partager ce constat
bertrand de craie sur la nécessité
d'avoir de la prévention pour prévenir
quelqu'un comme ont pu connaître
dernière le meunier d'abord quand
j'écoute ce drame c'est très triste très
triste 5 6 ans ça m'a touché et par
contre je le paye mais voilà après j'ai
donc je ne me hasarderai pas aux
définitions c'est quoi ça commence pas
par contre encore une fois et et j'ai
bien jusqu'à quand ce qu'on veut parler
de prévention j'entends bien moi je veux
dire deux choses 1 d'abord à quoi at-on
affaire de façon technique quelque chose
et puis je vous souhaite vous parler de
vécu parce que c'est des témoignages je
vous parlais que je vous ai dis encore
une fois 90% entreprises françaises ont
moins de 50 salariés
donc moi quand je vais vous dire en tant
que chef d'entreprise ce que je fais
donc j'ai pas de quatre bandas août chez
moi dieu merci mais là quand je voudrais
dire que je savais comment salariés le
burn out n'existe pas alors c'est pas
tout ce que je dis j'ai dit que comme
vous savez quand vous avez 10 alors 5 10
salariés si vous cavernes salariés vont
perdre hélas beaucoup 10% des effectifs
10% des effectifs dans les 500 pèlerins
portant l'effectif d'un seul coup c'est
vous tournez plus donc vous êtes
peut-être plus vigilants alors qu'il
accordait plus vertueux mais peut-être
plus vigilants à la santé psychique de
vos salariés vous savez un truc dont je
viens dans mon entreprise
tous les matins je salue
systématiquement tous les salariés
présents ici en un a commenté les vous
qui me répond pas bien
la deuxième question qui vient qu'est ce
qui se passe et dans ce que vous faites
et qu'est ce qui est bien à ce moment là
on en vient alors c'est peut-être ça
mais j'ai mal dormi la veille mme asha
des choses très simples ça peut être
j'ai perdu à prendre mais peu importe et
quelque part bon alors on a mis en plus
en place dans l'entreprise des cours de
yoga bon pour essayer d'avoir des trucs
de bon travail mais moi je n'ose trop de
pathos et qui vient travailler pour qui
sait pas de quoi vous ne répondrez
vermont mais ce que j'aime faire ça je
fais partie je pense tu fais partie
vraiment la responsabilité vous savez
quand on il faut aussi j'entends parler
mal de sa chasse secte et je sais ce que
c'est qu'un chsct
mais ayant moins de 40
les gens n'en ai pas je n'ai pas
l'exercice si vous voulez j'entends ce
musée madame avec l'international
changements qu'on tourne et on a refait
mon boulot mais j'entends je sais que ça
se passe mais si vous voulez dans notre
vie nous deux patrons ce parce que le
bleu mais des 110 est composée à 99% de
patrons de tpe et de pme et qui sont
traumatisés quand on veut notamment
parlé on entend on entend des choses
comme la pénibilité le beurre noisette
on s'est dit m quelle charge la position
nous c'est vous en fait on pouvait
s'attendre à bernabeu pour les dons de
personnes auxquelles vous êtes en train
de nous parler de quelle charge d'argent
mais oui on cela reste assez chaque fois
aussi à chaque fois c'est grâce à
françois 2 on est très loin vous dire
que c'est vraiment une dépression coin
les gens souffrent des dépressions et
ils ne sont plus en capacité d'aller au
travail ne peuvent plus se lever ils
n'ont plus d'objectif il ya plus d'élan
vital
il ya plus de désir ya plus de projets
ya plus rien ça atteint la famille ça
atteint le conjoint moi j'ai des couples
dans ma consultation qui sont en
instance de divorce
j'ai des gens qui se déchire la maman
qui travaille et qui rentre à la maison
qui n'en peut tellement plu que
finalement les enfants deviennent le
souffre douleur
il ya tout ça d'ailleurs le burn out 1
c'est pas une petite affaire
de l'autre côté chien quand même à dire
que quand un salarié parce que je crois
qu'il faut continuer à demander à ce
qu'il y ait des reconnaissances en
maladie professionnelle
quand un salarié fait la demande auprès
de son médecin généraliste qui fait la
demande auprès de la sécurité sociale et
qu'ensuite on fasse toutes les démarches
derrière nécessaire le salarié s'engage
dans une dans un vrai parcours du
combattant
c'est extrêmement difficile douloureux
et les salariés ne cherche pas à mettre
les petites entreprises
en difficulté il cherche seulement à ce
qu'on puisse identifier le fait que
s'ils se sont écroulés c'est bel et bien
parce que le travail est pour quelque
chose et c'est tout pour conclure je
vais reprendre les gens qui semblent en
out sont des salariés qui sont très
investis dans le travail qui le travail
a un sens énorme et un jour ou l'autre
il se passe une rupture émotionnel
qu'ils aient bien tout cela
tout ce que j'ai fait voilà voilà
comment comment on me remercie et voilà
comment ça arrive donc de l'importance
d'un travail qui ait un sens merci c'est
en tout cas un gouvernement juste a
ajouté que moi cette souffrance que je
vivais au travail parce que cette
entreprise vous avez bien compris je
vais pas là lui entière du mal parce
qu'il ya vraiment deux personnes des
personnes formidables dans cette
entreprise mais ce que je veux dire
c'est que j'ai occulté cette souffrance
parce que je me suis dit je vais aller
de l'avant et on va m'entendre et
personne n'a entendu personne m'a aidé
personne n'a aidé mon mari mes enfants
m'ont aidé ma famille proche m'a aidé et
je veux je veux repartir je veux
repartir et je savais très en sortir on
m'a détruit juste jeu
oui je veux penser que c'est possible de
s'en sortir
j'ai intégré le fait que ça prend du
temps parce que c'est une démarche
vraiment lourdes lourdes pas et d'un
point de vue aussi sécurité sociale
parce que moi au mois d'octobre on m'a
dit vous pouvez reprendre le travail en
burn out ça dure de 1 mois à 3 mois et
je ne savais pas de quoi on parle et
j'allais pas intégré le mourre d'earn
out encore complètement et comment vous
pouvez dire que je peux reprendre le
travail je suis incapable de me lever
correctement le match alors que vous
êtes encore on le voit d'ailleurs touché
par par tout ce qui s'est passé en tout
cas merci d'être venu témoigner merci à
tous les trois également d'avoir
participé à ce débat
n'hésitez pas à réagir y aura beaucoup
de réactions c'est sûr sur le twitter de
l'émission hashtags et huit sociétés on
se retrouve dans deux semaines pour
parler des rythmes scolaires
bonne soirée